soulagement parce que je n'ai pas
déjeuné samedi suis angoissé jeudi sept
gars jouer mais que ça cesse ses
serveurs je ne peux pas avec la
président du comité jean emond le cycle
c'est moi également
maintenant je pense que l'année
prochaine on s'aperçoit que le même cas
de figure il faut que cette histoire là
que ça cesse donc en octobre il faudra
vraiment obligé vous rencontrer et
discuter
le concept est la meilleure solution moi
j'ai cherché je les appelais j'essaie de
discuter avec lui ça n'a pas été fait
mais je crois que il faudrait qu'un jour
qu'on se regarde dans les yeux
il aime le cyclisme ans également on n'a
pas les mêmes conceptions on n'a pas la
même vision des choses mais je crois que
nous aimons le site us ses parents se
déchirent dans un tribunal qu'on va
faire évoluer le sport
moi je crois que personnellement il ya
les types de marty qui arrive avec deux
africains se sont pas des français
ce ne sont pas des martiniquais ils sont
combien en france avec métropolitaine
je ne vois pas le problème avec nos
soeurs de la caille pourquoi nous ne
pouvons pas une ode au cours de ce tour
de la marque simplement